schwarze löcher scheinen eine viel
größere rolle im universum zu spielen
als bisher angenommen das ist das
ergebnis einer neuen untersuchung von 74
galaxien in unserer nähe
naja was man im kosmos sohn er nennt das
absolut frappierende die
supermassereichen schwarzen löcher ins
zentrum der galaxien sind nicht nur
quasi die resteverwerter und halten mit
ihren gravitation die galaxie mit
zusammen nein sie steuern auch die
entstehung der galaxien
je nachdem wie groß sie sind passiert
nämlich etwas vollkommen anderes in den
sternenhaufen was genau und warum jetzt
in kriegs und science fiction herzlich
willkommen
das ist wirklich ziemlich irre galaxien
werden quasi von den supermassereichen
schwarzen löchern in ihren zentren
gesteuert dass das ergebnis einer studie
eines internationalen forschungsteams
schon länger fiel auf dass die größe der
schwarzen löcher im zentrum von galaxien
mit der größe der jeweiligen galaxie in
einem zusammenhang steht je größer das
schwarze loch desto mehr sterne auch in
der galaxie und nicht umgekehrt aus
irgendeinem rätselhafte und gibt es
keine umgekehrte beziehung das schwarze
loch könnte ja zum beispiel größer sein
und weniger sterne in der galaxie übrig
lassen oder es könnte einen zufälligen
verteilung geben mal größer mal kleiner
und so weiter und so fort aber es gibt
eine ganz exakte beziehung die wurde
jetzt auch exakt bestätigt bei den 74
untersuchten galaxien gab es eine ganz
klare beziehung zwischen den
supermassereichen schwarzen löchern in
ihrem zentrum und der größe der galaxie
um zu diesem ergebnis zu gelangen
untersuchte das team das lichtspektrum
der galaxie und konnte so das alter der
sterne und damit die sternen bildung
beurteilen und das ergebnis ist absolut
klar große schwarze löcher sind viel
effizienter als kleinere in ihrem umfeld
entstehen viel mehr sterne viel
schneller
sie scheinen nicht nur selbst materie zu
verdichten sondern durch ihr
gravitationsfeld auch in ihrer umgebung
die verdichtung von materie
voranzutreiben und zitat bei den
galaxien mit einem massereichen
schwarzen loch wurde die sternbilder und
früher und schneller gestoppt als bei
denen mit kleineren
18 löchern so ignazio martin navarro von
der university of california
diese galaxien waren im schnitt 4
achtung vier milliarden jahre früher
fertig als galaxie mit kleineren
schwarzen löchern sie hatten also viel
früher 99 prozent ihrer endgültigen
masse gebildet als die galaxien mit
kleinen schwarzen löchern aber was
passiert hier genau zitat es gibt
verschiedene wege durch die ein
schwarzes loch energie in die galaxie
freisetzen kann und theoretiker haben
verschiedene ideen dazu wie das
abstoppen der stern bildung passiert
sagt aaron romanowski von der san jose
state university vermutet wird dass es
einen ganz besonderen zusammenhang gibt
sobald ein schwarzes loch in eine aktive
phase tritt und besonders viel materie
ansaugt könnte das die stern bildung
beeinträchtigen die entstehung von
galaxien würde demnach in ganz
bestimmten phasen erfolgen die durch das
supermassereiche schwarze loch im
zentrum gesteuert werden das schwarze
loch wäre quasi der puppenspieler der
die galaxie steuert und regelt ich bin
ja so gespannt auf das erste bild des
supermassereichen schwarzen loches aus
dem zentrum unserer galaxie der
milchstraße im april wurde sagittarius a
stern so heißt es von unzähligen
teleskopen synchronisiert aufgenommen
und wird gerade am in boston
zusammengerechnet täglich wird denn das
ergebnis kommen das wird der absolute
wahnsinn wenn er es nicht verpassen
wollte dadurch mehr ein abo aufs auge
und vergesst nicht den genau auf die
glocke nur dann werdet ihr auch immer
über neue videos informiert hier geht es
weiter mit dafür draufklicken wie sehen
schwarze löcher wirklich aus da geht es
genau um dieses foto das wir jetzt
vielleicht bald hoffentlich sehen können
also ansonsten bis dann bleibt da